i just turned 13 doing youtube for about
two years
yeah i'm at 142. what's one tip you have
for kids my age what do you want to
happen
cj just to inspire people if you want to
inspire people if that's really what
you're about then you don't need to do
anything but continue to put out the
content that you think will do that
whether they're 13 or 81 so many people
get into the rat race of how many
followers they have
and like that's just not the game that
you want to play you can't let your
self-esteem
or self-worth be wrapped up into metrics
on youtube
because it's one tiny proxy in the
reality of what you're up to
what's the name of your channel cj cj
bowling spell it
c-j-b-o-l-i-n-g slower because you want
them to actually [ __ ] follow you
cj b-o-l-i-n-g b-o-l-i-n-g
it would really mean a whole lot to me
if i've given you one
inch of value ever in my life for you to
follow this kid
let's let's see how many followers he
has on youtube by the end of this
weekend